you can be a left-leaning person and be
aware of all these kind of social issues
that affect us without being
miserable all the time and feeling like
you're you know an evil
[Music]
person Steven BAU welcome to how the
light gets in hey thanks for having me
so you used to stream games on Twitch
and more recently well over the past few
years you went more into the arena of
political commentary can you tell us
what initiated this shift I've been
playing games on Justin TV which was
become Twitch TV I think in around
2013 um from anywhere from I think
around 2010 2011 up to 2016 when the
Trump stuff started to kick off I saw
all the conversations happening and I
thought I'd throw my hat in the ring and
started having like political debates
I'd always been kind of like an
argumentative debate type person and I'd
always had like a peripheral interest in
politics but then with the Trump stuff
obviously everybody started to feel very
political online and yeah it felt
natural to get involved and because
there seemed to be a lot of um sort of
people who started off in the gaming
community so people like vosch people
like Hassan P I think even Milo yopos at
one point and then went into the realm
of political commentary and became quite
successful do you think there's a
certain set of skills or set of
characteristics that you know being
successful in one of those communities
makes you successful in the other
probably not I think that the overlap is
more likely that there's a if you draw
like a V diagram of like people
interested in playing video games and
then a v diagram of like online early
political pundits there's probably a lot
of overlap because of the demographics
like ex Skuse pretty young ex Skuse
fairly wealthy excuse fairly white um so
when you have all these things together
you're going to get a lot of overlap
between people that are you know in both
Fields I think I it's I'm of the opinion
that most of the people that came from
gaming had pretty bad political takes um
when you're involved in like a thing
that's peripheral to politics then your
entire political view ends up being
informed by like one issue so for a lot
of people that came from from the gaming
space it was like basically sjw and
being anti sjw and that was like their
entire worldview so you get a lot of
people coming out of the gaming space
that were kind of like prot Trump uh
just because they didn't like feminism I
guess and by didn't like feminism I mean
they didn't like being told not to say
slurs or not to be bigoted or whatever
by the evil woke sjw people so how do
you think someone like Hassan P could
became famous or someone like forch do
you think there was a specific political
issue that defined them or is that
slightly different um well I me I mean I
mean technically they both came up
through my community but um we were all
kind of like very farle people on the
internet and there was like a there was
like a wave of far right people so I
think that made each of us pretty unique
um vosch was pretty similar to me that
he was like a debate heavy left leaning
person and besides me there was nobody
else really doing that in 2016 2017 and
then Hassan kind of had the whole
Machinery of like The Young Turks behind
him um and then he started to get more
into Political commentary and then he
kind of skewed more towards like the
general Progressive ENT aining streamer
kind of guy and with someone like um V
so you said he rose up through your
community I'm guessing through a series
of debates maybe that he had with you is
that correct um yeah kind of like he he
was a caller on my stream way back in I
want to say 2011 maybe 2012 um and he
did that for maybe eight or nine years
we'd hop on stream we'd have an argument
and then he started a YouTube channel a
few years ago and then we did some more
debates and then eventually I tend to
split apart from other political people
cuz we can only be in each other's
Orbits for so long before we start to
HTE each other I guess so the people who
become successful so someone like VOR
Who Rose up through your community what
kind of characteristics do you think
they possess that makes them so
successful like what makes someone such
a such a successful sort of twitch
streamwork but in the realm of political
commentary for well I mean these things
will change every year right because the
landscape evolves so dramatically but
back then I would say it was willing to
put in some effort to research willing
to have like sharp rhetorical skills
willing to be pretty edgy and then
inhabiting like a left-leaning political
ideology um those characteristics again
besides me were pretty rare so I think
there was a lot of hunger and thirst for
it on the internet to see kind of like
that group of people come up to fight
against all of the kind of like the
right-wing edgy people there's a sort of
thought with a A lot of people
especially the more mainstream
commentariat which is that platforming
people with two extreme opinions is
actually legitimizing a certain form of
opinion that we don't want to legitimize
and therefore we shouldn't allow that to
happen yet you to take the opposite
approach which is you debate people who
many would say would have quite extreme
views from both sides of the aisle so
Nick Fuentes on the right for example
and maybe communist on the left why do
you think why do you go for that
approach as a as opposed to the former
approach for as long as we live in a
democracy where every person has one
vote whether you're homeless or a
billionaire or whatever um we have to
trust citizens I think to be able to
have complicated and challenging
conversations and this idea that we have
to take like I can understand platform
saying like no no racial slurs or
something like that's fair but when we
start like axing off entire parts of the
ideological spectrum that we're not
allowed to talk about whether it's like
covid or vaccinations or um election
denial or whatever um it does really bad
things I think to the discourse uh it
makes the people on the right feel
unheard which they should feel heard
even if I don't agree with them it makes
people on the left Dumber because now
they don't have any opportunity to kind
of like sharpen their uh I guess blades
fighting these types of opinions and
then it just kind of drives all of us
into these further uh like uh further
radicalized like Echo Chambers where
nobody has any idea what what's actually
going on like anytime I see a person on
the right and the left come together and
talk now they just in their minds they
just have the most ridiculous
caricatures of the others opinions and
nobody even knows how to have a
conversation anymore and do you think
those caricatures have become worse over
the past 10 or 20 years because people
like to say that we we live in a more
Tri politically tribal world uh some
people push back against this but do you
think that's that's true do you think
people's opinions of each other have
become more caricatured over the past 5
10 years and if so what I would say over
the past five years for sure um there's
the hard one that everybody suffers from
a bit of re recen ISM everybody feels
like they're in the worst political
timeline ever I would say that the last
5 years has been unique because I think
for the first time ever we have the
internet and we've got a lot of money
and power behind pushing certain types
of content to people that is basically
having them view the same type of
material over and over and over and over
and over again I don't think we've ever
had a setup on planet where you've got a
profit incentive on a worldwide thing
that encourages people to only consume
one type of content like I think if you
go back like even 15 20 years ago before
the internet was as big you still had to
be somewhat grounded because you had
neighbors you had your local community
you see people at church you see people
at the union you see people at school
but now you can have whatever insane
opinion you have you can go online and
probably find a community of like 5,000
people that have it regardless of how
insane your opinion is and I think that
kind of thing is relatively unhealthy
YouTube operates and and for example Tik
Tok more and more appeals to a narrower
attention span uh in some respects and
how do you think if anything does that
affect the sorts of views that uh does
it make people more politically extreme
does it affect the sorts of views people
might have has it has it changed the
political landscape do you think um I
think short form content is bad for a
variety of reasons uh that has to do
with how basically how we move through
and enjoy life probably has a negative
knock on effect for political opinions
as well I'd imagine the if I've only got
30 seconds to show you something it's
probably not going to be a detailed
breakdown of a budget it's probably just
going to be the most Sensational
emotionally loaded thing I can get you
with because I've only got 30 seconds to
hold your attention so I imagine if
you're incentivized to create extremely
emotionally provocative content it's
probably going to be worse overall for a
more nuanced political conversation but
I will say I feel like we've always kind
of tended towards more extremely
provocative emotionally evocative
content even in mainstream media so but
I'm sure Tik Tok and everything
accelerates that you do a lot of content
and it seems to have a lot of different
themes to it some will be political
commentary some or some will be research
streams some will be arguments with
other people in coming up with ideas for
your videos and coming up with themes
for your videos do you have a specific
line that you take is there a way that
you try to structure I think it's
basically just whatever interests me at
the time um yeah I have I have a really
R Variety of interests and then if
something interesting pops up we'll
probably start diving into it uh some
this works sometimes to my benefit I can
cover a lot of really unique topics that
a lot of other people won't cover
sometimes it works my detriment because
sometimes there stuff that's maybe
pretty important but I super don't care
about it like there's uh Trump did his
last Town Hall I think like a month ago
for I don't remember which News Channel
I didn't even want to watch it because I
I've already heard everything Trump has
to say over and over and over again so
obviously my audience wants me to watch
it but I'm like I don't want to watch
Trump do his you know five minute SP
again yeah do you think he could win
Trump y could Trump win um I mean I
would have said absolutely not in 2016
and he did
yeah uh personally I don't think so uh
the reason why I would say no is because
one he's already lost to Biden once and
it's not like the as much as a
Republicans say it like the United
States is doing pretty well a lot better
than we thought we'd be we were
expecting huge recession it didn't
really happen we thought inflation would
stay forever didn't really happen some
Republicans are waiting for a world
world I I that hasn't happened yet I
guess um so I think Biden is doing a
decent job uh Trump already lost to him
once uh Republicans have made a really
big deal out of the abortion thing which
I don't think is like a political
popular thing to do and they've got a
really bloody primary coming ahead of
them so I feel like the Republicans are
primed in a lot of negative ways for the
upcoming election but who knows could
you run down what you think are the
strengths and the weaknesses of this
current Democrat Administration and
specifically
Biden uh for strengths I mean
legislatively like I think in the first
year or two I think people would have
said that Biden accomplished more than
anybody thought he'd ever be able to do
so legislatively the administration is
very strong I would argue that foreign
policy wise I think it's fairly strong
uh some people were unhappy that uh the
Afghanistan pull out wasn't as nice as
it could have gone but at least we out
um and I'll give a major props to that
Trump said he would get us out he pushed
it off until the next election uh so I
mean at least we're out of Afghanistan
and I think the United States has done a
really good job at taking leadership on
the Ukraine issue with Russia uh but
then that's contentious among people on
the very far left and then a lot of
people on the right so yeah and then
also there were like early day successes
as well like I think we B the economy
pretty well for Co he got that 100
million vaccinations and like half the
time he said he would uh even though
maybe that's not 100% you know Biden to
Biden's credit but um in terms of like
on leadership I think that he he has the
demeanor of a president which is nice to
not have to look at Twitter to see what
my leader is saying every day in
the world stage U foreign policy wise he
has a respectable foreign policy he's
not like doing crazy stuff all the time
no photo ops with insane people um
yeah in terms of K uh I mean the age is
going to be a big one I mean you you
watch him talking about Bosnia 20 30
years ago and you compare that to today
he definitely is is slowing down a bit
uh sometimes I wonder if he's a little
bit too milk toast like I kind of Wonder
I look at Biden in my opinion I feel
like Biden is he's pretty hard to hate
because he's not like that polarizing
but he's also really hard to like get
behind CU he's not like that exciting
you know whereas Obama was a person that
Republicans love to hate and the
Democrats love to love uh Biden is just
kind of there I think he does a good job
but in kind of a boring way so people
don't care as much um yeah so I think KH
is it literally comes down to I guess
like energy and it feels kind of dumb to
say that but I kind of wonder sometimes
if some of the elections might be
decided basically exactly on that sure
and you said something earlier which I'd
quite like to come back to and link to
this conversation which is there are
some issues where the left have become
Dumber on those issues I.E a sort of
complacency because people haven't come
together and argued or had to defend
those issues sort of similar thing to
what George Orwell said which is that if
he'd encountered a flat earther he
probably wouldn't be able to win the
argument because he didn't know the
counterarguments to that wait who said
that George Orwell okay I say the same
thing he CED me I think um but go back
to that what specific issues do you
think that applies to most today every
everything every single social issue um
and the United States Democrats are
arguing no hold on I I need to be
careful when I say this um where the the
political distribution of people in the
United States right now is very strange
if you go online progressives basically
run everything yeah uh but in the real
world progressives are a minority of the
democratic voting block and they have
almost no political power but they seem
to be very active culturally and in like
schools and everything the progressives
kind of like have the Reigns on all the
social issues that I feel like they're
running farther and farther away from
where people are at organically in the
conversation like if you talk to a
progressive they would tell you that
like the debate today needs to be
whether or not like a four-year-old can
be considered trans and in the United
States I don't even know if the normal
voter has completely bought into anybody
being trans yet like my guess is
probably 30 to 40% of Americans don't
even believe that transness is like a
real thing at all the Republicans have
made like trans issues the focal point I
guess of the past like year and a half
of all of their policies of all of their
talking points of like I feel like every
single day I go on Twitter there's like
seven guys from the daily wire talking
about Leah Thomas or some trans issue or
some culture wors thing related to trans
stuff or another book in a school yeah
um I feel like more specifically just I
I guess I feel like progressives when
they go to argue about a lot of these
Niche social issues there's very little
understanding very little compassion
very little empathy if they run into
somebody that disagrees with them they
basically immediately write them off as
like a racist a bigot a sexist a fascist
and then they don't really have the
ability to even engage in that
conversation so so far it's been okay
because the Trump disaster and the
Republican party has kind of inhibited
them from making like good political
gains but if the Republicans get back on
their feet again um if D Santos provides
good leadership or if God forbid Trump
figures the out and comes back um I
think that culturally the progresses
have put the Democratic party in a
really weird spot like for instance in
um in in 2022 um we did really good in
the elections I think a lot of it had to
do with abortion and um and Trump's bad
leadership but like earlier than that
the BLM riots and the push for socialism
and the all cops are BAS rhetoric from
the progressives even though they're a
minority of the party really hurt a lot
of mainstream Democrats in their
elections so Matt Walsh recently uh made
a documentary in which he essentially
went round asking a a load of professors
and people on the street what is a woman
if he were on a debate panel with you
and you debating him and he he just came
to you with that question how would you
answer that question or how do you think
someone should answer that question it's
a really difficult one so the reality is
is one of the the most important
faculties that humans develop that is
unique from every other animal on the
planet uh regardless of what a vegan
will tell you humans are the only
creature on the planet that have a
sophisticated capacity for abstract
thought and language um language that
goes beyond just i bark and you come but
in terms of being able to communicate
like I can communicate a negative to you
I can tell you something is not there I
can communicate something at a future
time and date in another area these
types of things that humans have for
language it is incredibly complicated
language is one of those things that we
learn when we're one year old and we
never think about it again
unb compated terms how
language there are t of writers Vic
probably is going to have strong
opinions on this for me personally as an
uneducated whatever when I think of
language or I think of words I think if
we say a word and when we say that word
you kind of invoke this family of
Concepts around the word and they light
up stronger or weaker depending on what
you're talking about um so depending how
cheeky you want to be if somebody asks
you like what is a woman right you want
to have a strong answer but the reality
is that these are really complicated
things for instance even on a simple
thing if I ask you like what is a chair
you're not going to really give me a
strong answer it could have four legs it
could have three legs it could be made
of a soft material it could be made of
uh hard material it could have no it
could be like a big beanie bag right um
the reality is that when we say chair it
invokes kind of this family of Concepts
and I think the same is true for for
women as well uh if you want to talk
like biology if you want to talk
chromosomes like these are all things
that are loosely associated with woman
that's true however when we're existing
in public and we identify like a man or
a woman we do that without seeing the
chromosomes without seeing the genit
without any sort of with very few
biological indicators sometimes we'll
just do it on clothes or like voice
right um you know we can identify online
people as uh men or women so I actually
really liked uh if you watch that
documentary there were a lot of good
answers given by a lot of different
people I thought Jordan Peterson
actually had some good answers now when
they play his answer in the documentary
they've got like the serious music and
Matt Walsh is coming to him for the
answer so it seems like he's saying
something reasonable but his answer is
really just as kind of loose as
everybody else is I think I think the
final thing he says to Matt Walsh is
like so how do I find out what a woman
is and J Peterson is like well why don't
you marry one and find out you know
which is kind of how we discover
everything in life and in language is
you kind of it's like that family of
Concepts and you just keep associating
with it and then you refine and you
iterate on that family of Concepts as
you you know add and remove qualities
based on what a woman is or what a woman
isn't you know people with long hair
people with smooth skin people blah blah
blah blah blah yeah there's often this
view I think particularly from the left
that look cultural issues aren't
particularly important because they
don't really affect people in Mater ways
whereas sort of Economic Policy things
like that actually do do you think
that's a fair argument or do you think
people are missing something when they
say our cultural issues aren't really
important this is just some kind of
innan distraction yeah so they're called
meat and potatoes issues right and it's
something that the middle class and
wealthier people uh have no
understanding of and they what happens
is is I think a bunch of athl people
will get in a room together and they'll
say poor people don't care about these
stupid social issues they want to make
more money that is absolutely not true
there are people that will vote away
every dollar they and food stamps and
everything on certain social issues like
abortion right there or there are
certain social issues that will drive
every strata of society what do you
think that is um well I mean like stuff
related to Children is going to be a
really big one um stuff related to
abortion is a massive one in the United
States uh LGBT issues can be a big one
but yeah this is a mistake that I don't
think they make the same mistakes
anymore but political pits or political
pollsters and politicians used to make
the mistake that like poor people just
care about meat and potatoes issues they
don't care about social issues but
that's absolutely not true sometimes
poor people care about social issues
more than wealthier people because
they've got you know less of a stake
even in kind of the whole like wealth
game you know I would argue actually I
just on that topic even for brexit I
feel like brexit was largely driven by
social issues especially immigration I
think even though some people try to
talk around and say it was Financial or
say it was economic I I it doesn't feel
that way I don't think so when I look at
the rhetoric and I look at the the
sentiment that was driving brexit
actually happening there something else
on cultural issues that I I wanted to
ask ask you about um so Jordan Peterson
since 2016 has become very famous around
this idea a lot of it's putting forward
um gender roles um you've been very
critical of the way in which he
discusses general you know the idea that
men operate within a dominance hierarchy
and they're trying to work their way up
that dominance hierarchy and what do you
think of that whole thing I my issue
with Jordan Peterson is that like I'll
agree with most of what he says on a
descriptive level
um like I think it's important to
recognize differences between men and
women they're real they exist obviously
and there's different ways that men and
women function in society but I think
that sometimes we make the mistake in
society of we we'll we'll we'll look at
men and women where they are and we'll
assume that they could only ever be
there because of our biological
differences and then we ignore the
massive social drivers that we have that
push us deeper into those fields so like
in my opinion in a totally Equitable
World totally equal everybody has the
same opportuni same upbringing blah blah
blah and I think even in that world
you'd still see men and women choosing
differently um based on the profession
profession but you're not going to see
like 90% of men and 10% of women in some
areas it's going to be like 55 45 or
maybe a little bit larger maybe a little
bit smaller depending on the area but I
feel like sometimes we we make this
mistake of like well women have always
done this so they'll never want to do
this in the future and I think that at
least in the United States keep in mind
when I speak I'm always speaking us
social ISS it might be a slightly
different other parts of the world but
the United States I think access to the
workplace and access to birth control
has like fundamentally altered women's
relationship with Society in ways that I
don't think anybody would have ever
believed nobody would have thought that
like women could outperform men in math
for instance because boys play with uh
toys and and uh you know women play with
Barbie dolls and women are more social
and and boys are more abstract and
discreet in numbers and blah blah um but
we were're starting to see for Education
that wasn't the case right or the idea
that oh women don't enjoy uh
recreational sex they'll never do that
that's horrible you know women are The
Gatekeepers and blah blah blah and it's
like well I don't know with access to
birth control and they have the ability
to have recreational sex without getting
pregnant all the time it seems like some
of them do enjoy recreational sex and so
the scary thing about people like Jordan
Peterson is sometimes he'll come in with
these Just So Stories he'll say well you
know women are like this and men are
like this and because of this
biologically these things are never
going to change and it's like some of
these things might change and I think we
need to be a little bit more receptive
or understanding of where those changes
are going to happen so that we could be
ready for it in the future and you've
debated quite a few people who are fans
of Andrew Tate within that category
there people like on the fresh fresh and
fit
where do you think all that comes from
and do you think it's linked to any of
the Jordan Peterson stuff yeah I mean I
think it I think there is a I think
we've made really good strides in
society bolstering a lot of different
types of minorities so be it women or
people of color or LGBT people but it
always feels like on the backs of all
those movements we always have to make
sure everybody knows how much we hate
white people or we want to kick down on
men or whatever um and I think that when
you do this for year after year after
year over a decade you you get this kind
of growing sentiment of young white guys
MH or even young men in general um who
just kind of feel left out or they feel
like they don't have figures to look up
to or they feel like they're constantly
being told they're not good they're
toxic etc etc all the time and when that
happens you you get this hunger from
that group of people to find figures to
look towards Jordan Peterson filled that
role originally and now it's like all
these red pill spaces and Andrew Tate
that are kind of exploding and filling
that new void and what's the best way
you find of disarming a lot of their
arguments I I mean it really it depends
on the person I mean none other
arguments are based in very good data so
if somebody wants to sit down and
actually go through studies that could
be a good way to do it um a lot of the
time I think what people really need to
see on that side is people want to be
happy and enjoy life and sometimes in
the left it's really hard to do
that right so if I look on the right and
I see Andrew Tate like what's Andrew
Tate telling me he's telling me buy a
sword be the master of your own destiny
go get you know work get Bugattis get
get do all this stuff it's like
okay well if I go to the left what are
they telling me it's like well you need
to feel bad because you're white and
you're systemically oppressing everybody
and capitalism is evil and you're
privileged and everything you do is just
because of your mom and dad it's like
okay well me right I feel like the
left comes down in you so hard and it
makes you feel like for everything
in society you know like oh those shoes
those were made by in a slave shop or oh
that food that you bought the person is
a victim of capitalism and they probably
don't have a pension and it's like okay
and then on the right like you get like
all these people that feel really
empowering they drive you further and
further so I feel like on the left often
times I feel like my important role is
to show that like hey I'm here I've got
a lot of really Progressive beliefs but
I'm a happy person I live a fun life
like I make money I don't think that any
of this is evil and yeah having having
like more figures like that I think
would be really important to show that
you're not demonizing success and that
you can be a left leaning person and be
aware of all these kind of social issues
that affect us without being
miserable all the time and feeling like
you're you know an evil person who have
you found the most intellectually
impressive or formidable person you've
debated
um the problem is that if you're part of
an ideological movement the debate is
going to never feel that that fun
because chances are you are um you're
captive to that audience and you're
never going to change right like if if
you're literally like your name is like
red pill Rolo or red pill Creator right
like you're never going to be like oh
that's a good point maybe uh maybe women
aren't like evil divorce monsters you
know like you're not going to admit that
because you're going to lose half your
audience doing it uh honestly I think
some of my best debates are probably
just people in my community that I pull
on to have conversations with um there's
a few well-known members in my community
that just jump on my Discord to argue
with me I think those are the most fun
because these are people they don't have
strong attachments to any like political
groups or ideology so they have a lot
more flexibility to kind of like grow
and change and like give me new and
interesting ideas whereas on a lot of
these online political spaces you
honestly God you hear like the same four
or five figures every single day
from these people it might be about
trans kids or some person in a bathroom
or a trans athlete or whatever you hear
this for like a year on red pill space
it's like 80% of women initiate divorce
and men are supposed to do this and
women do that and it's like the same
thing every single day so yeah people
that are less ideologically aligned in
my personal opinion are more fun to
argue with with because they have more
flexibility and room to grow and they
provide like a more unique perspective
to argue against and are there any
issues that they've changed your mind on
um yeah I've changed my mind on a ton of
things over the years I don't know if
I've had any major shifts in opinion
recently the last big one I had was
probably being persuaded away from the
citizens united thing in the United
States had to do with campaign finan
something there was a really big deal
now I don't think it's that big of a
deal at all um oh I guess for Ukraine um
before The Invasion I never thought it
would happen and I kind of didn't care
much about the Ukrainian issues but then
once the invasion happened I did like
two weeks of pretty hardcore research
and got a lot more information there I
guess I wasn't a big like changing of
the mind yeah yeah I've been pretty
ideologically stable but I've also the
past year has been like me fighting red
pillars a ton so nobody's convinced me
to hate women yet I guess so I haven't
really changed much there great Steph
Bell thank you very much thank
you